All right, so
now we have this array of dictionaries
for each photo in the results.
We could use the first photo
dictionary in the array and
populate the image view and
the label and call it done.
But to get the user the best experience,
we should pick a random photo from
these dictionaries so that a user has
a chance to see a different image each
time they press the button in the app.
Let's start by generating a random index
that we can use to select a random photo
dictionary.
We can do this by using
the arc4random_uniform function and
this returns a number from zero
to the argument that we specify.
In this case we want a number from
0 to the highest possible index
of the photoArray.
And you'll notice that we've done this
casting to a UInt32 type because that's
what this function expects.
We'll do this in the same way that we
access the other values, but we want to
make sure that we use the randomly
chosen photo dictionary here and here.
And we convert both of
the values to strings.
So we're converting
the MediumURL to a string, and
we're converting the title
here to a string.
Then to check that
everything works properly,
let's add some print statements and
run the app.
Awesome, now we're getting the URL and
the title.
And I know this is a really long
bad title, but it is a title.